[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi 3
met tout de suite les titres de cette
édition
le projet de fusion entre coignières et
maurepas ne passe pas auprès de certains
habitants ir soir près de 200 personnes
se sont réunies devant la mairie de
coignières pour montrer leur opposition
au même moment à maurepas les élus ont
validé le lancement de l'étude pour la
création de la commune nouvelle
le refuge spa de plaisir lance son
premier printemps des animaux ils se
déroulent ce week-end l'objectif est
d'encourager les adoptions en légère
baisse en france l'an passé elles deux
cents chats et 120 chiens sont dans la
tente de trouver un foyer à plaisir
entretien à suivre et puis la semaine
prochaine aura des allures de vacances
avec deux jours fériés beaucoup
devraient profiter des ponts à venir si
vous restez cependant dans les abîmes
pas de panique nous avons sélectionné
pour vous quelques idées de sorties dans
ce journal également nous recevrons de
membres du football club phénix de
versailles cette équipe de football
regroupant et des réfugiés demandeurs
d'asile et sans domicile va fêter cette
son premier anniversaire ça sera à
dimanche on en parle tout à l'heure dans
le journal suite de la grève demain des
cheminots de la sncf un mouvement perlé
contre la réforme ferroviaire du
gouvernement et du cou à quelques
perturbations encore à prévoir demain
vendredi pour les utilisateurs de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 1 train sur 3
sur l'ensemble du réseau qui passe par
l'agglomération le rer c la ligne n est
la ligne u les horaires de vos trains
sont à consulter sur le site
transilien.com la volonté a été affichée
début avril et maire de maurepas et
coignières veulent rassembler leur ville
en une commune nouvelle
un projet qui est loin de faire
l'unanimité si le lancement de l'étude
sur la fusion a été voté hier soir en
conseil municipal à maurepas elle les
habitants de coignières eux se sont
rassemblés devant leur mairie une
mobilisation pour s'opposer à ce
rapprochement reportage de mélanie potée
de ville pour un même projet deux
ambiances ce mercredi 2 mai elle était
électrique devant la mairie de
coignières où devait se tenir le conseil
municipal finalement annulée en raison
des soucis de santé du maire jean-pierre
sevestre
près de 200 personnes réunies pour dire
non à la création d'une commune nouvelle
il regrette la soudaineté de l'annoncé
craignent une perte d'identité de
coignières au profit de maurepas je
tiens à l'identité de poignard de caen
aériens se sont mobilisés cet homme et
se mobiliseront encore si c'est
nécessaire pour qu un poignet
rennes ne soit pas rayer de la carte de
la france doit être mis devant le fait
accompli
c'est vraiment inadmissible on a
découvert en fait que j'avais ce projet
de fusion qui n'était pas forcément
prévu donc ça nous a forcément
interpellé est amené à être curieux sur
le sujet à vouloir en savoir plus une
volonté de rapprochement annoncé le 9
avril dernier l'une des raisons avancées
pour ce projet faire face à la baisse de
la dgf les dotations de l'état
à voir toutes les capacités d'aborder
les différents dossiers les différents
projets que nous pouvons avoir notamment
les projets importants que nous avons
sur la ville de coignières sur les
années à venir
l'argument n'est pas recevable pour les
membres de l'opposition à coignières à
l'origine du rassemblement
car les finances de la commune sont
saines une fusion entraînerait pour eux
en revanche une forte augmentation des
impôts locaux
mais c'est dgf ne représentent que 7 %
de nos recettes de fonctionnement
donc c'est presque rien ici on a les
entreprises on a tout ça donc c'est
presque rien on peut totalement se
passer de la dgf c'est peut-être pas la
même situation à maurepas
une pétition pour demander la tenue d'un
référendum local sur le sujet a été
lancée elle aurait recueilli près de
1500 signatures à coignières ou le
projet ne passe pas a également pour
quelques élus la majorité ils seraient
huit membres du groupe majoritaire sur
17 à s'opposer à la création d'une
commune nouvelle avec maurepas nous
sommes quelques-uns
dans certains sont des membres du bureau
municipal à avoir donné un avis très
défavorable à la fusion qui nous paraît
être un projet insuffisamment mur en
tout cas en l'état actuel des choses et
d'autre part c'est un c'est une fusion
qui est très déséquilibré au détriment
de notre commune au même moment ce
mercredi 2 mai se tenait le conseil
municipal à maurepas l'ambiance était
chaude et quelque peu après un échange
houleux avec le premier adjoint et
roanne le gall l'élu d'opposition ps
ismail havane a décidé de quitter
l'assemblée le conseil municipal a
finalement adopté le lancement de
l'étude concernant la création d'une
commune nouvelle avec coignières deux
élus n'ont pas pris part au vote dont
ismaïl à vannes 4 se sont abstenus pas
d'opposition un rapprochement avec
coignières sur le fond mais tout s'est
fait beaucoup trop vite
la communication a été très mal faite
c'est vraiment dommage parce qu'il y
avait certainement des choses à voir
ensemble de façon à ce que chacun soit
gagnant malgré l'approbation de maurepas
le dossier de fusion est pour le moment
stopper temps que le conseil municipal
de coignières n'aura pas valide et
également le lancement de l'étude
commune entre les deux villes une fois
que les études ont été votés du côté de
coignières on pourra aller lancer
ensuite engager la suite en tout cas
nous avons un calendrier nous souhaitons
poursuivre les réunions publiques et les
ateliers de travail et que les habitants
au moins avant l'été avant d'arriver au
vote avant la fin d'année
dans un communiqué distribué aux
habitants lors du rassemblement la
municipalité de coignières indique
qu'elle va organiser une concertation
collective pour décider de la suite
donnée au projet de création d'une
commune nouvelle avec maurepas un marine
chapa poursuit à ses visites à trappes
jusqu'à demain à vendredi la secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes étaient en visite à
la pépinière d'entreprises située rue
eugène pottier quatre sociétés lui ont
présenté leurs activités dans les
domaines de l'ingénierie l'automobile un
moment d'échangé autour de
l'accompagnement des femmes vers
l'emploi elles sont encore peu présente
dans la création d'entreprise ou dans
certains domaines et des propos
recueillis par nicolas landry
moi ya des choses qui sont
par exemple il ya une formation qui va
débuter courant du mois de mai sur le
numérique dans les cas il ya un effort
qui a été fait par la directrice de la
baignade pour faire en sorte qu'ils
aient une mixité et qu'il y ait
plusieurs femmes prennent ces cours de
codage et qui suivent cette formation
gong le constat c'est l'inégalité entre
les femmes et les hommes passés dans la
création d'entreprise et
particulièrement dans ces secteurs là
les solutions on est en train de
travailler collectivement je pense
qu'elles seront nationalement cette
semaine les élèves reprenait les chemins
de l'école mais avec les deux jours
fériés à venir et des ponts la semaine
prochaine prend des allures encore de
vacances
bonsoir camille lambert en sport vous
êtes la spécialiste loisirs de la
rédaction alors pour ceux qui ne restent
qui restent dans les yvelines ce ne sont
pas les activités qui montrent que vous
avez concocté pour nous je vais y
arriver quelques idées de sorties
exactement alors que vous soyez
passionné d'histoire et de culture ou
plutôt aux amateurs de randonnées et de
sensations fortes les opportunités ne
manquent pas la saison a repris dans bon
nombre d'établissements france miniature
l encours est ouvert même pendant les
jours fériés de 10h à 18h l'occasion
d'en profiter pour re découvrir le parc
en compagnie de stéphane bern c'est la
nouveauté de cette année il a prêté sa
voix pour un guide les châteaux aux
yvelinois aussi camille sont prêts à
accueillir le public pour les jours
fériés
et oui du faste de versailles aux contes
de perrault à breteuil il y en a pour
tous les goûts
le château de rambouillet est lui aussi
ouvert tous les jours sauf le mardi
après plusieurs années de travaux il
s'est refait une beauté et depuis fin
mars l'appartement de l'empereur et
remeubler vous le voyez sur ces images
rien de mieux pour s'imprégner du cadre
des séjours de napoléon 1er au domaine
de rambouillet est toujours à
rambouillet sachez que le train à vapeur
du musée rend boli trains a repris du
service depuis le 1er mai petits et
grands peuvent prendre place à l'arrière
du wagon pour une promenade dans les
jardins va vous parliez randonnée
sensations fortes
également la météo sera clémente la
semaine prochaine donc autant en
profiter pour prendre un bol d'air frais
en pleine nature
et oui à pied à cheval ou
vélo c'est selon selon ses goûts donc
explorer la vallée de chevreuse par
exemple le spécialiste des circuits à
vélo la société fourchette et manivelle
propose des séjours plus ou moins longs
avec un guide pour découvrir la forêt de
rambouillet et ses alentours de 2 heures
à trois jours pour les plus téméraires
quand même même les moins sportives mais
les moins sportifs peuvent participer
car ce sont des vélos à assistance
électrique donc plutôt pratique pour
monter les côtes on va pas se mentir
pas de jour précis c'est à vous
d'appeler pour réserver votre visite
il faut être minimum de cette période de
l'année avec les beaux jours qui
reviennent camille est ce que c'est là
le moment idéal pour jardiner et oui si
vous possédez un jardin rendez-vous à la
grée knotek de la médiathèque jean
rousselot à guyancourt ce samedi 5 mai
les associations locales vous donneront
des conseils et vous pourrez faire du
troc de graines à planter chez vous et
si vous ne possédez pas de jardin vous
pouvez quand même profiter des plantes
hockeyades de gally ou de villepin les
dernières tulipes sont à ramasser mais
les pivoines et les oyés pointent leur
premier pétale les cueillettes vous
accueille du mercredi au dimanche de 10h
à 18h alors grigori quel sera votre
programme plutôt aux fleurs ou plutôt
sport vous connaissez bien camier plutôt
sport vous l'avez sans doute déjà
entendu en rédaction c'est même plutôt
du football on parlera justement
football dans un instant du football
solidaire un sujet régionale d'abord
c'est le préfet de l'île de france
michel cadot et qui rencontrait la
presse aujourd'hui l'occasion de parler
de l'actualité francilienne et notamment
de la situation des migrants sur le
territoire reportage de via grand paris
des centaines de tentes alignées au bord
du canal saint denis sur ce qu'est
proche du centre commercial millénaire
1500 migrants vivent nuitées jour depuis
mars
750 places d'hébergement ont été
ouvertes par la préfecture d'île de
france
elles sont réparties dans cinq centres
d'accueil et d'examen de situation
ce nouveau dispositif doit remplacer la
bulle de centre de premier accueil porte
de la chapelle
chaque semaine près de 500 migrants
arrivent à paris le dispositif
actuellement fonctionnent et suffisants
pour traiter le flux arrivant
des migrants donc on a une capacité qui
est capable de traiter dans des
conditions satisfaisantes le flux des
centres d'accueil et d'examen de
situations qui n'enraye pas la
multiplication des campements dans la
capitale beaucoup des occupants de ces
temps tu ne souhaites à monter dans les
propositions de
de transport sur les centres d'accueil
et d'examen de situation administrative
que nous leur adressons à marjah mais on
a entre certaines fois 30 à 40 % de
refus parfois même un peu plus que la
moitié
une évacuation du campement du
millénaire est pour l'instant à l'étude
mais elle n'est pas imminente en ma
responsabilité ainsi que celle du préfet
de police d'ailleurs rouge maintenant
est de réfléchir les façons dont on peut
préparer une éventuelle évacuation et
mises à l'abri des personnes concernées
donc nous sommes dans cet état puis
simplement actuellement de réflexion de
travail depuis 2000 15 30 camps ont été
évacuées dans le nord est parisien
cette équipe regroupe des réfugiés des
demandeurs d'asile et des personnes sans
domicile à versailles le football club
phénix de versailles fait c'est un an à
l'anniversaire sera fêté ce dimanche à
14h30 au stade de jussieu c'est toujours
à versailles alors l'équipe regroupe les
dix des réfugiés des demandeurs d'asile
des personnes également sans domicile on
en parle avec deux invités qui sont avec
moi un plateau à yassa bourbon soir on
sort vous êtes soudanais joueurs du
phénix football club vous aurez
l'occasion nous raconter un petit peu
votre histoire
raphaël besson également avec noah
plateau bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
fondateur et bénévoles de cette équipe
secrétaire de l'association voisins
solidaires de versailles qui est à
l'origine donc de ce projet un an pour
cette équipe de football pas comme les
autres ça signifie quoi ça signifie 130
joueurs de 14 nationalités différentes
beaucoup de beaucoup de bonheur pas mal
d'espoirs des déceptions et un peu de
souffrance
pourquoi lancer cette équipe quelle est
cette équipe c'est en tout a commencé en
concourant fin 2016
on a été amené à aborder aller les
réfugiés qui était dans le centre de
l'inra et petit à petit on a trouvé
qu'ils étaient un peu désoeuvrés
et laissés à eux-mêmes et assez
rapidement on s'est organisé pour les
soutenir les aider et puis petit à petit
c'est est sortie l'idée de monter une
équipe de foot c'est ce qui semblait le
plus fédérateur et les universités allez
vous relancez sûr ça le football c'est
un sport fédérateur justement pourquoi
choisir ce sport le football parce que
c'est le sport de toutes les
nationalités qu'on a pu côtoyer c'est
vraiment le sport qu'il est le plus
connu
en plus on a la chance d'en dans les
jeunes dégâts qu'on a vue d'avoir des
anciens footballeurs professionnels
donc c'était c'était une belle
opportunité et c'est vraiment universel
et voilà donc on a pas mal d'afghans qui
voulait qu'on fasse du cricket par
exemple mais bon ça on a pas on n'a pas
beaucoup de compétences par les coûts de
l'infrastructure non plus pour ça donc
voilà le football est venu assez
naturellement il ya le football pour
vous ça représente quoi c c'est
important comme sport pour vous ouais
c'est très important pour moi j'essaie
compte un dg au football faire partie de
cette équipe le phénix à football club
qu'est ce que ça vous apporte au
quotidien
donc ça nous apporte beaucoup de choses
à moi précisément à moins ça m'apporte
beaucoup des choses parfois quand je
pars je suis le football à fournissent
tout ça parfois j'ai chose les idées
quoi
gvg bruit j'ai traversé un moment
difficile mais j'ai eu beaucoup de
soucis dans ma tête quand j'ai
partenaires à pourvoir
il est responsable monsieur raphaël tout
ça ça me fait plaisir de jouer au
football comme beaucoup premièrement il
le fait de jouer sa vie de l'esprit
saint qui s'analyse aspects du gris pour
faire des heures 3 heures étant avec les
jeux bon c'est très important plus loin
que je reste à la maison tous est
d'accord racontez nous un peu votre
histoire comment vous êtes arrivé
justement dans cette équipe de foot oui
dans cette équipe de foot moi je suis
venu à mortemart c'était le 1er
septembre 2010 est d'accord et que je
disais mais si raphaël et les autres
bénévoles élevé à côté des mortels pour
nous refaire discussion tant que c'est
pour cela on a parlé avec et et ils ont
monté une équipe
oui donc chaque samedi j'ai joué avec et
c'est très important pour ça est-ce que
vous avez l'impression de renaître au
sein de cette équipe
est ce que c'est quelque chose depuis
que vous êtes arrivé dans cette équipe
de football ça ça vous fait beaucoup de
bien ouais ça me fait beaucoup de bien
ça me fait plaisir ça me fait beaucoup
des choses que si on vient justement sur
le nom de l'équipe phoenix football club
on peut penser que ses joueurs ont vécu
des choses horribles dans leur pays
peut-être voilà ils vont ils ont ils ont
souffert le fait de venir dans cette
équipe
le nom phoenix s'adonnent aussi l'idée
de renaître
c'est un peu pour ça qu'on a qu'on a
pris ce nom ait alors c'est ça peut
paraître un peu prétentieux mais
effectivement dans leur pays ils ont ils
ont vécu beaucoup de choses dans leur
voyage aussi par exemple si on prend
l'exemple de yahia il me racontait il ya
quelque temps il a mis il ya trois ans
quatre ans j'ai même pour pour rejoindre
là encore l'europe donc c'est super
compliqué et donc on veut leur donner un
petit peu d'espoir pas leur donner parce
que on n'est pas du tout maîtres de leur
avenir mais faire en sorte que leur à
leur quotidien soit un petit peu plus un
peu plus doux et qu'ils sentent qu'il ya
un peu de de fraternité de d'humanité
voilà et donc nous on est super contents
parce que les les gars se mélangent
quelle que soit la vente sûrs qu'ils ont
vécu le
l'origine de leur pays ou même leur
classe sociale
il ya vraiment un bon un bon mix ça et
ça c'est vraiment appréciable
il nous reste moins d'une minute qu'est
ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour ce
premier anniversaire quel projet
peut-être sur sont en cours alors pour
pour chacun de nos gains
d'arriver à avoir une vie apaisée et à
l'auteur de leur as de leurs espérances
pour le club en général de pouvoir
continuer cette aventure on est
relativement bien accueillie par un
parent versailles
que ce soit les associations locales les
habitants ou ou même la ville donc voilà
on veut pouvoir continuer à se
développer et puis continuer à donner un
peu toujours un petit peu d'espoir et de
fraternité a dit on souhaite en tout cas
jouer les anniversaires et je rappelle
que la lisière du football club phénix
aura lieu ce dimanche le aversa et 14h37
au stade de jussieu vous pouvez
d'ailleurs retrouver plusieurs
informations sur sur ce club via un site
internet qui s'affiche actuellement en
bas de l'écran merci d'avoir été avec
tôt en 2010 est près de 40000 chats et
chiens ont trouvé chaleur et amour dans
un foyer grâce au refuge de la spa
un chiffre en légère baisse par rapport
à l'année précédente alors pour
encourager les adoptions le refuge de
plaisir organise ce week-end pour la
première fois le printemps des animaux
120 chiens et deux cents chats sont
ainsi dans la tente de trouver une
famille et nicolas qui le vise c'est
mario ptac ont rencontré le responsable
du site entretien
[Musique]
le printemps est de retour sur les
yvelines le printemps qui va s'installer
le beau temps ce week-end notamment et
le printemps aussi à la spa de plaisir
avec le premier printemps des animaux
marie-laure car on vous êtes la
responsable du refuge ici à plaisir en
quoi ça consiste cet événement qui se
tient samedi et dimanche le printemps
des animaux
alors donc effectivement c'est la
première fois que nous organisons le
printemps des animaux au refuge
on avait envie en fait de commencer le
printemps sur une note positive
puisqu'ils l'hiver a été long froid et
donc là avec le beau temps qui est
arrivé on avait envie de mettre en avant
nos animaux leur donner aussi la
possibilité de trouver une famille pour
ce printemps et qu il le passe dans de
bonnes conditions et pas derrière les
barreaux
on axe sur le côté printemps au mieux en
se disant peut-être qu'il va faire beau
le beau temps est de retour et que du
coup peut-être que les gens vont sortir
on voit avoir l'idée de venir ici pour
trouver un animal de compagnie c'est
toute façon quand il fait beau en
attendant ça va se déplacer beaucoup
plus que quand il fait très mauvais et
comme on a gardé un hiver vraiment très
froid très pluvieux on n'a pas eu
beaucoup de beaucoup d'adoptions temps
pas autant qu'on aurait aimé
donc là on fait avec ce printemps on
veut vraiment essayer d'optimiser nos
chances pour faire adopter nos petits
pensionnaires et puis aussi bien pour
malheureusement préparer l'été qui va
être très dur on sait que
malheureusement plein d'animaux vont
rentrer pendant cette période
donc là on espère vraiment faire de la
place pour pouvoir en sauver d'autres
est ce que le printemps est une période
plus idéal que peut-être une autre
période pour pour accueillir un animal
de compagnie dans le foyer peut-être
aussi quand il faut sortir le chien
c'est plus facile de commencer au
printemps que pendant l'hiver est ce que
c'est aussi ça le l'objectif de ce
week-end alors oui et non parce que du
coup quand les gens viennent a dit à
adopter en hiver bombe à la mèche
allumée vraiment dans la réalité
même quand il fait beau il faut sortir
l'animal
là après nous on explique toujours quant
aux usa dopent quand il fait beau que
même l'hiver faudra sortir le chien
qu'il aura besoin de se dépenser et même
s'il pleut ou s'il neige faudra le
sortir donc là c'est parce que je pense
que les gens sont quand même peut-être
plus ouvert et après en fait c'est juste
aussi que les gens pensent à nous et
pense à nos animaux c'est pas toujours
encore un réflexe de venir à la spa
adopté on a des animaux super sympa qui
m'a qui attendent juste un bon foyer
donc voilà c'est pour motiver dans ce
sens là peut-être quelques quelques
conseils à savoir pour ceux qui vont se
déplacer soutiennent peut-être avoir des
l'idée peut-être de ce qu'on recherche
ou ou peut-être imaginer qu'on n'est pas
tous faits pour avoir tous types
d'animaux voilà alors c'est vrai que
certaines personnes ne peuvent être un
petit peu braqué puisque quand ils
viennent pour un animal en particulier
si les conditions ne correspondent pas
ou que le caractère du chien ne
correspond pas aux adoptants ils ne
pourront pas repartir avec l'animal le
but vraiment c'est de trouver l'animal
qui reste pour qui correspond bien au
foyer pour que ce soit une réussite pour
la famille et pour l'animal on prend
vraiment en considération le caractère
et puis le rythme de vie des gens si
vous avez des gens plutôt calme plus tôt
et qui n'aime pas sortir trop souvent
qu'ils se promènent vraiment que le
week-end et vraiment c'est une petite
promenade on va pas leur place et un
chien hyperactif
de toute façon il va les fatiguer plus
qu'autre chose donc on essaie vraiment
de trouver l'animal qui correspond bien
à la famille il ya des animaux aussi qui
peut-être nécessitent plus d'attention
que d'autres tout à fait il ya des
chiens qui ne peuvent pas ou des chats
qui ne peuvent pas rester tout seul
toute la journée parce que c'est trop
long pour eux trop angoissant donc donc
le but vraiment c'est c'est de trouver
vraiment le duo entre les cas le voilà
le couple qui va qui va correspondre
pour que ce soit une réussite pour tout
le monde
après le l'idéal c'est de venir en
famille pour que justement l'animal
rencontre aussi les enfants puisque tous
les enfants n'ont pas forcément le même
comportement et le chien ou le chat va
aussi avoir un comportement différent en
fonction de l'attitude de l'enfant
donc on aime bien que la famille entière
se déplacent ici on vient à la spa de
plaisir si ça ça match avec un chien un
chat on repart dans la foulée avec
comment comment ça se passait des
examens aussi peut-être médicaux à
passer voilà tout avait donc on va
essayer donc justement d'être prêt pour
ce week end donc nos animaux vont être
vu
sur les deux jours la troupe ce qu on a
rentré malheureusement beaucoup
d'animaux cette semaine donc ils vont
être vues par notre vétérinaire pour
pouvoir partir ce week-end
donc si les les familles ont les
papiers qui correspondent à cela notre
attente c'est à dire un justificatif de
domicile pièce d'identité et chèque de
caution si l'animal n'est pas encore
stérilisés ils peuvent tout à fait
repartir avec avec l'animal voilà vous
avez toutes les informations pour venir
ici à la spa de plaisir au refuge il y à
300 animaux un peu plus de 300 animaux
de compagnie qui vous attendent samedi
et dimanche entre 10h et 18h avec le
soleil pour mettre un peu de soleil dans
la vie des animaux et sûrement de la
vôtre aussi
tu
eux aussi vous donne rendez-vous ce
week-end mais à rambouillet 130
agriculteurs et producteurs venus de
toute la france sont réunis pour le dix
neuvième marché pari fermier à la
bergerie nationale à partir de samedi et
jusqu'au 8 mai est les visiteurs sont
attendus pour découvrir les spécialités
régionales et le savoir faire de nos
agriculteurs ja de serre crêpes aux
oeufs d'autruche ou glaces artisanales
un rendez-vous qui met à l'honneur la
gastronomie et le terroir propos
collectées par camille lambert et
mélanie poquet on est en plein dedans
dans le circuit court pardon et vente
directe ce qui est vraiment important
pour nous c'est de montrer aux visiteurs
et consommateurs que quand ils viennent
sur un pari fermier
ils ont en face d'eux l'agriculteur qui
donc produit élèves et transforme ces
circuits courts vente directe il n'y a
pas d'intermédiaire pas de commerces pas
de commerçants pas de revendeurs etc
c'est pareil dans le vin vous n'avez que
des vignerons ya pas de négociants pas
de pas de revendeurs c'est vraiment le
vigneron qui en face de vous avant de se
quitter je vous propose un voyage dans
le temps un bond dans le passé de plus
de 300 ans versailles accueillera ce
week-end l'événement esprit jardin
l'occasion notamment de redécouvrir le
potager du roi créé par louis xiv
mais juste avant aurélie ronces et
patrick jacques de dixmude vous emmène
dans les coulisses d'un restaurant et
qui propose des plats servis à l'époque
du roi soleil
regardez
[Musique]
déguster du boudin noir sucré salé comme
au temps du roi soleil
c'est l'expérience culinaire que vous
propose ce restaurant versailles et si
les recettes sont élaborées dans une
cuisine moderne
elles sont toutes puiser au sein de
livres datant du xviie ou xviiie siècle
on peut trouver de la sole de l'arrêt du
perdreau du chevreuil
ce sont des ingrédients qui se
trouvaient sur les tables des rois ou en
tout cas de noble de la cour de cette
époque et nous revisitons les recettes
pour les adapter aux goûts du jour bien
évidemment et est proposé un menu
haut de gamme mais le concept ne
s'arrête pas là bienvenue dans la cour
intérieure ici vous trouvez la table des
comédiens et c'est ici qu'ils s'amusent
à jouer aux cartes
tout au long de ce repas gastronomique
des saynètes sont joués
histoire de vous plonger encore plus
dans les secrets de la cour de louis xiv
les comédiens viennent à votre table
vous raconter des anecdotes
croustillantes qui ont qui sont
historiques qui ont réellement eu lieu
ou en tout cas rumeurs historique et ils
viennent vraiment au contact pro proche
de vous c'est un peu comme si vous vous
surprenez une conversation dans les
couloirs du temps entre deux personnages
du xviie ou xviiie siècle en fonction de
la pièce de théâtre que vous choisissez
coût du voyage dans le temps à partir de
100 euros par personne et après un repas
fastueux
rien de tel qu'une petite promenade dans
le potager du roi crée entre 1678 1683 à
la demande de louis xiv féru de
jardinage
il ouvrira ses portes au grand public à
l'occasion de l'événement esprit jardin
parmi les choses de cette époque ci qui
sont excellentes et font nous font du
bien
les épinards des salades construit par
jean baptiste laquintinie le potager du
roi était chargé de fournir en fruits et
légumes la table du roi soleil il est
aujourd'hui classé monument historique
et jardins remarquables
c'est un jardin un grand carré central
avec un bassin divisé en croix sur les
points cardinaux et toute une série de
jardin qui font le tour c'est les
premières représentations du jardin en
occident la particularité de ce jardin
c'est d'avoir maintenu ce dessin de
l'avoir respecté depuis sa création avec
quelques petites modifications
rendez vous les 5 et 6 mai à 15 heures
pour faire un bond dans le passé et
découvrir ce lieu confidentiel
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal très
belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]